why do people listen to sad music um i
mean one reason is
their hearing expressed for them like
the musician is basically saying to them
this thing that you have experienced
i've experienced it too so have lots of
other people and but they're saying it
all without words and it's transformed
into something beautiful
and there's something about that that's
just incredibly elevating and people
don't know it but
like there's one study that i have in in
bittersweet that found that
people whose favorite songs are their
happy songs play it on their playlist
about 175 times but the people who love
sad music play them about 800 times
and then and they say that they feel
connected to the sublime when when
they're listening to that music
what what do you think that is so what
is that
what what is it in music that connects
us to the sublime through sadness
i mean i have a bunch of different
theories like
the whole reason i started
writing this book
is because i kept having this reaction
reliably to sad music
and
i realized that
for people who i knew who were religious
believers the way they described their
experience of god
was what i was experiencing when i would
hear that music
like all the time it happens over and
over again so you you wonder what that
is
yeah so i started wondering what that is
um and lots of people have
tried to figure out you know what that's
all about um
and there are different theories that
it's expressing it's like a kind of
catharsis for our difficult emotions um
that it's as we were saying a sense of
being in it together
we don't react in that sort of uplifted
way
when you just see um
like a slideshow of sad faces which is
something researchers have actually
tested no one really cares when they're
seeing the slide to the sad faces but
the sad music they're really reacting
and also they don't really react when
they're hearing music expressing other
negative emotions like martial music or
something like that it's just the sad
music that gives people this elevated
sense of wonder
so i think it's the combination of the
sadness and the beauty
and i think it's just tapping into
the essence of the human source code
which is a kind of spiritual longing
whether we're atheists or believers
there's this feeling of longing for
a state and a place of perfect love and
perfect unity and perfect truths and all
of it and like an acute awareness that
we're not there in this world and you
know
in religions we express that through the
longing for mecca or eden or zion
and artistically we express it with
dorothy longing for somewhere over the
rainbow or you know harry potter
enters the story at the precise moment
that he's become an orphan
so he's now going to spend the rest of
his life longing for these parents who
he can never remember
and that's
there's something about that state
that's at our very core and i think
that's why we love it so much well it
could be you know you could have the
ernest becker theory of uh denial of
death where at the core of that the warm
at the core
as jung said is the uh fear of death so
where the longing
for the perfect thing is has to do with
sort of
becoming immortal as uh
reaching
beyond the the absurdity the cruelty of
life that all things come to an end for
for for no particularly good reason
whatsoever or one we can rationally
explain i know you know i wonder about
that all the time like
i know obviously there's that idea um
from becker and throughout philosophy
and the tale of gilgamesh about the idea
that the thing we're longing for most of
all is immortality
but
i feel like it's not only that i think
it's
more so or also let's say um a longing
for
the lions to lay down with the lambs
finally you know for like the
the fundamental calculus of the universe
to just be different where life doesn't
have to eat life in order to survive
and
yeah just a completely different
situation i wonder that that
immortality would not solve
i wonder
that could be a very kind of
uh modern thing
because
surely so much of human history is
defined by violence and glorified
violence that doesn't give inklings of
this lions and the lambs
so much
i mean i know all the other stuff is in
the bible to you there's other stuff in
the bible in the bible and this is that
particular aspect doesn't necessarily
reveal the fundamental motivation of
human nature that could be deeper stuff
you know
but that yeah that is a beautiful
that is a beautiful picture but
is it just about humans or is it all
about
about all of life and you have to think
about
what is the perfect world look like it's
not just the lines and lambs laying
together
it's
you know
how many lines how many lamps right and
uh you know what
having just had a few
very technical conversation about
marxian economics versus kenzian
economics versus neoclassical economics
what does the economic and the
government system look like for the
lines and the labs that we're longing
for
so that then you start to build society
on top of all those things and
you but you still you return to this
what what is it what are we longing for
and what's the role of love in that
what's the role of
that sad melancholy feeling the feeling
of loneliness is the feeling of
loneliness fundamental to the human
condition like
are we always striving to sort of uh
channel that feeling of loneliness
uh to connect with others like we want
that feeling of loneliness otherwise we
wouldn't be connecting is that
fundamental
that feeling like
you're alone in this even when you're
with other people sort of alone together
you're born alone you die alone maybe
loneliness is fundamental i think that
longing for union is fundamental it's
just that it looks so different for
different people you know
yeah and coming back to where we were
what we were talking about at the
beginning you know
union looks incredibly social for a lot
of people and hardly social at all for
others but everybody needs some version
of union
you